salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
vous en avez peut-être entendu parler il
y a quelques semaines l'acteur et
comédien Fabrice luukili annoncé avoir
vendu sa maison sur l'île de Ray il est
persuadé qu'elle sera noyée sous les EAU
d'ici une dizaine d'années alors a-t-il
fait le bon choix une chose est sûre
depuis un peu plus d'un siècle le niveau
des océans ne cesse de grimper et ce
n'est pas prêt de s'arrêé avec le
réchauffement climatique et la fondte
des glaces la France métropolitaine avec
5000 500 km de côte est directement
menacé alors comment en est-on arrivé là
et jusqu'où ça va monter c'est l'objet
de cette
vidéo en ce moment vous en entendez
parler tous les jours ce tient à Dubaï
la COP 28 la COP ou Conférence des
Parties conférence of the parties pour
respecter l'acronyme est un sommet
annuel durant lequel 197 États se
réunissent pour discuter des politiques
à mener pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique parmi les
sujets les plus préoccupants chaque
année il y a la montée du niveau des
océans dans son dernier rapport le GC
groupe d'expert intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat constate qu'entre
1900 et 2018 le niveau moyen de la mer
s'est élevé de 20 cm et le phénomène
accélère alors que la hausse du niveau
s'établissait à 1,4 mm par an en moyenne
durant la période 1900 1990 il gram
désormais à 3,6 mm par an au rythme von
des choses le niveau des océans pourrait
augmenter de 50 cm d'ici 2100 les
scénarios les plus pessimistes
envisagent même une élévation qui
pourrait dépasser 1 m d'ici la fin du
21e siècle voici à quoi pourrait
ressembler le trait de côte dans moins
d'un siècle si le niveau des océans
monte d'un m en rouge ce sont les zones
tière qui pourra être submergé par les
EAU en 2100 les plus touchés par ce
phénomène sont l'embouchure de la scène
la côte atlantique est dans une moindre
mesure la côte méditerranéenne parmi les
grandes villes les plus menacées on
trouve le Havre camp Bordeaux Arcachon
d'ville Bayonne Toulon et 7 certains
sites touristiques comme la bsum pourrai
carrément être engloutis pour mesurer
les dégâts provoqués par la montée des
EAU pas la peine de se projeter dans le
futur la mer a déjà gagné du terrain
dans de nombreuses zones sur le littoral
akittin par exemple elle a par endroit
avancé de 100 à 150 m symbole de ce
phénomène l'immeuble le signal situé à
sous LAAC surmer en Gironde construit en
1967 il était à l'époque à 200 m du
rivage il n'était plus qu'à une dizaine
de mètres de l'eau il y a quelques mois
pour éviter qu'il ne s'écoule dans
l'océan il a été détruit en février
dernier le constat est le même sur la
côte méditerranéenne au Sainte-Marie de
la mer par exemple dans les Bouches du
rô les experts estiment qu'avec la
montée des EAU la commune pourrait très
bientôt devenir une presquî une partie
de la camarg est d'ailleurs condamné à
disparaître puisque la majorité de son
territoire est situé à moins d'un MRE
au-dessus du niveau de la mer en France
près d'1,4 million de personnes
pourraient vivre sous la ligne de marée
haute d'ici à 2050 depuis laquitain ou
Haut- de France en Charente Maritime où
se situe l'île de Ré les perspectives
sont toutes aussi alarmante à en croire
un rapport publié par climate central un
organisme américain ce département sera
sérieusement impacté d'ici 2050 et une
carte établie par le bureau de recherche
géologique et minière montre que l'île
perdrait 50 % de sa surface si le niveau
des EAU augmentait d'un m ça c'est
d'ailleurs déjà produit pendant quelques
jours en 2010 après le passage de la
tempête xintia comment expliquer cette
montée du niveau des
océans depuis o on l'a dit le niveau des
mers mesuré par les marégraphes et plus
récemment par les satellites est monté
de 20 cm en cause le réchauffement
climatique il est dû aux émissions de
gaz à effet de serre liés à l'activité
humaine les gaz à effet de serre sont
naturellement présent en faible quantité
dans notre atmosphère le rôle est
déterminant dans le maintien d'une
température terrestre vivable les gaz à
effet de serre retiennent en fait une
partie du rayonnement infrarouge
provoqué par par le rayonnement solaire
le problème c'est que l'augmentation de
la concentration de gaz à effet de serre
dans l'atmosphère fait grimper le
thermomètre à la surface du globe la
température s'est élevée d'un peu plus
d'un degré par rapport à la période
pré-industrielle en France c'est un peu
plus
1,7°g c'est le constat indiscutable
qu'on fait les experts du j qu'il y ait
une corrélation entre l'augmentation des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre depuis
le début de l'airre industrielle et
l'augment ation de la température à la
surface de la planète le premier de ces
gazes c'est le dioxyde de carbone CO2 il
provient essentiellement de la
combustion des énergies fossiles le
charbon le gaz et le pétrole qu'on
emploie dans l'industrie à la maison ou
encore dans les transports deux autres
gazes sont impliqués le protoxine
d'azote émis par la production d'angr
agricole ou encore les gaz fluoré
employé comme réfrigérant dans les
climatisations et enfin le méthane les
principales émanation de ce gaz sont
produites par le système digestif des
ruminants les vaches et les
moutons l'une des conséquences du
réchauffement climatique ça tne sous le
sens c'est la fonte des glaces quand on
évoque ce phénomène on pense tout de
suite à la banquise pour le nord comme
au pôle sud elles font à vue d'œil les
scientifiques estiment par exemple que
l'Arctique pourrait être privé de sa
banquise en été dès les années 2030
c'est demain dans les fait ce sont des
milliards de litres de glace qui
retournent à l'état liquide
mais contrairement aux apparences ce
n'est pas ce qui fait monter le niveau
des océans j'explique à la différence
des glaciers continentau du Groenland et
de l'Antarctique qui sont composés d'eau
douce continentale la banquise elle est
composée d' d'eau de mer elle est le
résultat de la congélation de l'océan
entre -1 et - 2 degr autrement dit c'est
un énorme glaçon qui flotte sur un
énorme récipient la mer comme ce glaçon
plongé dans un d'eau rempli à rabord qui
apparaît à l'écran et que se passe-t-il
quand le glaçon fond rien le niveau
reste le même et bien le même phénomène
se produit avec la banquise l'eau de
fonte occupe
exactement le même volume que la glace
occupait sans modifier le niveau de la
mer on l'a compris c'est donc pas la
fonde de la banquise qui fait monter le
niveau des océans il faut plutôt
regarder du côé des glaciers terrestres
notamment les calottes qui recouvrent le
Groenland et bien sûr l'Antarctique
reprenons l'exemple du glaçon cette fois
il est placé à l'extérieur du verre
alors que celui-ci est toujours plein à
rabord j'ai ajouté une petite gouttière
pour canaliser l'eau de fte bien vous le
voyez quand le glaçon font le niveau
monte et cette fois le verre déborde
selon leogque la fonte des glaces va
s'accélérer considérablement dans les
années à venir mais jusqu'à présent elle
n'était responsable que de 50 % de
l'élévation du niveau des mer on va
faire une autre expérience j'ai rempli
cette éprouvette avec de l'eau froide
j'ai fait un petit trait rouge pour
marquer le niveau je vais maintenant
plonger
l'éprouvettes dans une tasse remplie
d'eau chaude observez bien le niveau
dans
l'éprouvette sous l'effet de la chaleur
l'eau se dilate et le niveau MTE c'est
ce qu'on appelle la dilatation thermique
et bien il se passe exactement la même
chose dans les océans à cause du
réchauffement climatique la température
de l'eau augmente et l'eau se dilate le
niveau mon et ce n'est pas terminé la
fonte de la banquise accentue ce
phénomène de réchauffement la surface
blanche de la neige a pour effet de
réfléchir la lumière du soleil et donc
de réduire la production de chaleur
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet d'au sauf
que la banquise se réduisant d'année en
année cet effet est de moins en moins
important et l'océan est de plus en plus
exposé au rayons lumineux donc à la
chaleur on l'a dit d'après certains
scénarios du GC la banquise d'été
pourrait disparaître à l'horizon 2030 au
pôle Sud d'après une étude paru dans la
revue Nature climate change une partie
de la calotte glaciire de l'Antarctique
occidentale devrait disparaître quel que
soit le niveau de réchauffement
climatique et si la calotte fond c'est
bien l'eau liée à la fondte de cette
calotte qui va faire monter le niveau
des mers comme on l'a montré plus haut
d'ailleurs désormais ce phénomène est
devenu le principal responsable de la
montée des eau avant la dilatation
conséquence au moins 570 villes risquent
d'avoir de l'eau jusqu'au genoux façon
ne parler des mégalopoles comme New York
Shanghai ou Tokyo qui sont situés sur le
littoral sont donc particulièrement
vulnérables à la montée du niveau des
EAU alors est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il
n'y a plus rien à faire surtout pas même
si le phénomène n'est pas réversible
chaque diè de degré gagné permettra de
réduire les effets du réchauffement
climatique les expert estiment qu'il
atteindra 1,5°gr à l'échelle de la
planète dès le début des années 2030 je
vous rappelle qu'en 2015 lors de la COP
21 les pays participants se sont engagés
à contenir le réchauffement en en
dessous de 2 degrés pour le moment on n
est pas et c'est le rôle de ces grands
messes comme la COP 28 qui se déroule en
ce moment à Dubaï de trouver les moyens
de s'en rapprocher le plus vite possible
c'est terminé pour aujourd'hui je pense
que vous l'avez compris la situation est
très préoccupante mais pas désespéré si
cette vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez pas à
laisser un commentaire et à vous abonner
si ce n'est pas déjà fait excellente
semaine à toutes et à tous et à très
bientôt sur la chaîne éep
[Applaudissements]